I don't care what you guys say Harry and
the Hendersons is legit no it was yeah
here's my birthday present that I got
you good
thanks so much except you're lying had
this next date last night oh that's a
job who wants to do a snippet
I love snippets uh actually wait there
whippets right yeah it's whip-it people
come snippets now what if we just ducked
out into the bathroom and got drunk like
usual that'd be fun no we are making
memories and then just find them okay no
that is hippy crack man did we not all
cried during that steve-o documentary
relax your mind I'm gonna blast off oh
wow we're just celebrating big ders
dog's birthday yeah it was because the
ders dawg online there's everything
that's happened soot sorry
nothing yeah he's monkeying around again
me whatever look there's a big surprise
for you in the break room it's a
birthday cake anyway I'm not going okay
Andres we have a dress code
can you please it's Greg Norman bitch